There was a Nazi train that was seized in
1945 that was filled with paintings,
artworks, gold and jewels.
Although large quantities of Nazi loot was
found, there's so much more that is missing
still to be returned to its rightful owners.
After the war. There are reports in Poland
of a Nazi train laden with gold spotted by
locals shortly before the allied invasion.
The train is estimated to contain 300 tons
of missing treasure worth around $10 billion.
This would represent probably the most
significant stockpile of stolen wealth in the
world. The key to the location of the train,
Dubinsky believes, is in the landscape.
Occupied Europe is. Devastating.
Towards the end of the war. By allied
bombers and the retreating Germans.
And post-war reconstruction further alters
the landscape.
Between the wartime allied and German maps
and modern satellite images.
There are many differences.
Certain features like railway lines, bridges
and tunnel entrances are present in the maps,
but are gone from the satellite images.
There are clues in the satellite images, but
you really have to know what you're looking
for.
But the satellite images are throwing up too
many potential hiding places.
Tyminski must narrow down the search.
This is a massive region.
It's criss cross with railway lines.
According to reports in Poland, towards the
end of the war, a heavily guarded Nazi train
was seen at a railway junction in Valle
Baji.
And that's where Tyminski is headed.
He has a lead.
A local man.
Today, Slav Tchaikovsky is a retired coal
miner who was just a boy when the Nazis
occupied Poland.
According to Slava Koski, the train spotted
here is rumored to be the private train of
Heinrich Himmler.
Thus Himmler.
Himmler's heavily armored private train was
an unbreakable behemoth over 500 feet long,
with two cargo carriages fitted with
anti-aircraft guns.
If Slovak Koski is correct, then Himmler's
train was on its way to the city of Wroclaw,
formerly Breslau, a small but well-guarded
Nazi outpost.
By the end of the war, the seemingly
insignificant city is being defended very,
very heavily at the cost of defense of, say,
Berlin.
It is thought that the Germans use Wroclaw to
store stolen loot and turn the city into Fort
Knox. But in 1945, it becomes clear the city
will fall to Stalin's Russian troops.
But before that, it is said that a train
loaded with valuables leaves the city.
This train is loaded and headed west to
escape the advancing Red Army.
But where might you hide a 5000 tonne train
loaded with gold?
Slava Bykovsky claims to have heard an
account from an eyewitness.
It's about what was made in that room.
Shabbir says that he met a witness, someone
who, towards the end of the war, claims that
they stood up onto the tender of a steam
locomotive and they could see two wagons in
tracks leading off into a tunnel.
Towards the end of the war, the Nazis are
known to have buried valuables in caves and
then blown up the entrances.
Did they do the same to the tunnel?
Collapse the ends of the tunnels.
And you have a perfect tomb, if you will, to
hide a whole bunch of loot.
But the Nazis didn't have time to dig new
tunnels as the Soviet army approached.
They must have used an existing tunnel.
As it happens, the Nazis were engaged in
digging out a large tunnel complex in the
nearby Owl Mountains.
There was this gigantic complex built
underground called Project Rizza, and the
railway line passes fairly close.
The long abandoned Nazi tunnels in this area
stretch for miles.
Precisely why they were built is not known.
This project is surrounded in mystery because
there's no documentation to suggest why the
Nazis would dig all these tunnels.
Tunnels are the obvious place to hide trains.
So I want to travel out to the RISA Project
Complex and have a look.
Only part of this immense underground complex
has been excavated.
There are miles of tunnels still to be
discovered and properly explored.
Many tunnels have collapsed or been blocked
off.
Above the complex satellite images show a
pine covered hillside and a nearby railway
line. Could they be connected?
Reaser is the German word for giant,
extending as far as six square miles.
The abandoned complex is one of the largest
subterranean structures on the planet.
The scale of these construction projects is
absolutely unimaginable.
The Germans build miles and miles of
underground complexes for hiding things.
The complex has only been partly excavated
and explored.
A large part of this labyrinth was sealed
off after the Nazis abandoned it in 1945.
It took 23,000 slave labourers dragged from
Nazi concentration camps to dig this
extraordinary tunnel complex.
They were almost all worked to death from
exhaustion and starvation.
Conditions down here must have been utterly
awful.
It is known that the Nazis used tunnels to
house secret armament projects like the
construction of the V2.
But what these tunnels were for remains a
mystery.
We can see bore holes where the dynamite
would have been placed.
Domanski is looking for clues.
Four tunnels tall enough to accommodate a
train for signs of train tracks for
indications that tunnel entrances have been
blocked or sealed.
All right.
That is something.
Nearly a mile into the hillside and DEMBOSKY
encounters a problem.
Whoa, Whoa. Ooh!
The tunnels are flooded.
To go any further.
Dubinsky must continue by boat.
Oh. That is amazing.
Why on earth were the Germans building this?
What does this all about?
The tunnels here are big enough to hide a
train, but it's hard to tell if there are
remnants of railway tracks beneath the
water.
Dubinsky needs to review the satellite
images.
There must be a spur connecting the railway
to this.
The question is where.
Dembosky will map the complex as best he can,
looking for a section of tunnel which might
lead from the nearest railway outside.
This is extremely exciting moment comparing
these two images.
Dubinsky is comparing wartime maps of the Owl
Mountain foothills with modern satellite
images.
Now I'm looking for houses that have been
knocked down during the war, and I'm also
looking to see whether there's any evidence
of subsiding land over a possible tunnel.
A train this valuable would have been very
heavily guarded and protected wherever it
ended up. There should be signs of other
activity around.
I'm looking for evidence of military
activity.
Dubinsky makes a short list of potential
sites.
This location is stronger than all the rest
because it is the closest to the reser
complex. The tunnel is.
The right length.
If I were a German general, I would hide the
train here.
Dubinsky sets out to search the area.
He believes the interior layout of the
resort complex suggests there may be blocked
off tunnels which extend beneath these
hills.
This has the look and feel of military
installation.
This is right by the tunnel.
So this could be related to the railway
line.
There is a modern train line built on the
ground of an older train line and a railway
tunnel still in use.
But Dubinsky won't be exploring it today.
For the new Volvo stud stock.
I've just been told that I can't go down
there because it's an active railway, which
is fair enough, but it does mean that I
won't be able to investigate inside the
tunnel.
There is no guarantee that the vast
quantities of missing gold plundered by the
Nazis ended up here.
But if it did, and if local reports are
correct, Dubinsky is convinced that an
armored train built for Heinrich Himmler
containing around $10 billion of stolen gold
may well be sitting right at his feet.
And he won't stop looking until he's found
it.